got the big UFC 296 the UFC is closing
the year just like they should this one
is a big boy this card is stacked even
the prelims are stacked but that main
card is so freaking tasty possibly card
of the Year depend how these fights go
down but it's has it uh Written in the
Stars this thing could be by far the
best card of the year it's good time to
be a fight fan um this is the the last
harra for 2023 the UFC's had a great
year it's been a good year for uh all
the people in the fight verse you could
say yeah this one's good and we we're
closing out the year we got a cass's
fight companion this Saturday with
Cheeto Vera Rampage and myself for UFC
296 it's a big boy so we had to bring in
the big guest and that's what we're
doing man so